san andreas stars the rock and it's
2015's the day after tomorrow Armageddon
deep impact 2012 this is probably gonna
be the fastest plot synopsis I've ever
given in a movie the San Andreas Fault
is splitting earthquakes disasters
buildings they fall the rock he rescues
people end of plot and that's it we go
to this movie you pretty much know
exactly what you're gonna get because
the trailers tell you what you're gonna
get a lot of CGI spectacle a lot of
explosions and buildings falling down
and rescue scenes and you get that
characters they're not really there uh
there's the rock and he's cool in all
seriousness though this movie knows
exactly what it is it's a big disaster
movie in which earthquakes continually
shake California buildings are falling
down people are constantly running from
dust and cars and people and ass and
guts and snot flying everywhere and the
rock rescues a lot of people and the
rock is cool so there it is that's your
movie I can't really see someone going
into this movie and being disappointed
because if you had high expectations in
regards to story and plot why I mean
haven't you seen every single disaster
movie ever it's really just a showcase
for great CGI and San Andreas has great
CGI there's a lot of really good scenes
and there actually are a couple
jaw-dropping on inspiring moments one
involving a boat and a tsunami and it
was pretty impressive the rock is good
in the movie carla Gugino I think is how
you say her name she was great too
alexandra daddario let's talk about her
a little bit lovely looking woman good
and true detective kind of bad in this
movie she did this overly shocked face
for a large majority of the movie and
yes in this situation I would be shocked
as well it's just it felt so
over-the-top then there's an actor like
Paul Giamatti who just is exceptional
he's great he's one of my favorite parts
of San Andreas he never feels like an
actor in this movie he just feels like
his character a scientist who was
exploring trying to figure out how to
predict these earthquakes and he did a
great job in the movie for the most part
the acting is fine there are moments
where they're trying to flesh out the
characters moe
we're involving a pass between the rock
and carla Gugino but there wasn't really
much else it was just the rock you're
cool and you can rescue people in your
helicopter and you're frickin cool and
that's really it so if you enjoy that
idea probably you'll have a good time
with San Andreas but for the most part
it's just an opportunity to showcase a
lot of awesome disaster sequences and
people running away from things that are
falling apart and after a while it
actually got a little boring because it
really is just the same thing over and
over and over but if I were to judge
this on like the disaster movie scale
you know where does this stand in
regards to all of these big gigantic
pictures it's not on the bottom it's
actually better than some of them I'm
gonna give San Andreas a C+ I think if
you just go to this movie knowing that
it's really just a bunch of buildings
collapsing and people running and the
rock is awesome and he saves people and
the rock is so cool and you're awesome
because you're the rock mmm but the
film's attempts to be deeper don't
really rise above the CGI spectacle so
it kind of falls flat in that regard
guys I'm curious to know what you
thought of San Andreas if you did see it
and as always thank you so much for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck on
iced
Oh